مع مرور خمس سنوات على اصابته يتمسك احمد
بالامل فلم يكتب اللغم الذي زرعه الحوثيون
وادى لبدر قدمه نهايه لاحلامه وشغفه
بالحياه
اصبت في 2017 وركبت طرف صناعي والحمد لله
الحياه مستمره لم تتوقف على البدر والامل
موجود
العمل المستمر والحمد لله
يرفض احمد التعامل معه كاحد ضحايا الالغام
يمارس حياته الطبيعيه والعمليه ويقوم
بتركيب طرف صناعي جديد في اليوم العالمي
للتوعيه بمخاطر الالغام رسالتي في اليوم
العالمي للالغام لا نريد التعاطف من
المجتمع الدولي والمتحده مع ضحايا الالغام
وانما نريد نزعل القام سحب خرائط الالقاب
من المليشيات الحوثيه المتضررين من
الالقاب خارج الجبهات اكثر من المتضررين
في الجبهات المدنيين الاطفال النساء
قتلت الالغام واصابت في زمن الهدنه اضعاف
الضحايا الذين سقطوا عند اشتداد المعارك
ارقام اكدتها تقارير المنظمات الدوليه
التي اعلنت ارتفاع اعداد ضحايا الالغام
ثمانيه اضعاف ما كانت عليه في عام 2021
ارتفاع تظهر نتائجه هنا في مركز الاطراف
الصناعيه الممول من مركز الملك سلمان في
زياده ملحوظه لاعداد الاطراف الصناعيه
التي وفرها لضحايا الالغام بلغت عدد
الخدمات المقدمه منذ بدايه المشروع في
2021 الى ما يقارب 46 الف خدمه مقدمه
لاكثر من 13,300 مستفيد تم تركيب اكثر من
1700 طرف صناعي لكافه شرائح المجتمع طبعا
يقدم المركز خدمات اضافيه مثل خدمه
التاهيل الفني اللي هي الصيانه الاطراف
الصناعيه بالاضافه الى خدمه العلاج
الطبيعي
تتصدر محافظه الحديده الساحليه ثم الجوف
الصحراويه اعداد ضحايا الالغام في اليمن
ورغم جهود الفرق الهندسيه التابعه لمشروع
مسام في نزع الالغام تتزايد اعداد الضحايا
مع مرور السنوات محمود الحميدي العربيه
مارب